thank you
not snow yet
your guess is as good as mine
we will stop
[Music]
foreign
we ready okay okay thank you
okay so good morning welcome it's very
nice to see some familiar faces here
um
thank you for joining and I'd like to
send a warm welcome to everyone in the
room and many of you who are online a
very warm welcome here
um and whether you're in this country or
overseas I know we have a number of
people from abroad who have dialed in my
name is Macarena I am the director of
communications here for the Church of
England uh once again a very warm
welcome
if you've covered the general Synod
before you'll know we usually have a
press conference a few weeks before a
meeting of Synod when the papers for the
various debates and pieces of
legislation are published today is a bit
different and an important day in the
history of the Church of England because
we are pleased to publish the outcome of
a special period of Prayer discernment
and decision making involving all of the
Bishops today we are announcing the
culmination of a process of listening
and learning across the whole of the
Church of England about questions of
identity sexuality relationships and
marriage stretching back over almost six
years the process was called living in
love and faith
we're delighted to be joined today by
the bishop of London Sarah Mullally who
for the last two and a half years has
been leading a group of Bishops called
the next steps Group which led a process
of church-wide listening and discernment
with Bishop Sarah is Dr Ayla John the
coordinator of the living and love and
living in love and faith process
throughout the last six years
you will also hear from the Archbishop
of Canterbury Justin Welby and the
Archbishop of your Stephen Cottrell
and in just a moment you'll hear from
William Nye the Secretary General of the
general synod
as you all know Synod usually meets two
or three times a year once in London in
February once in York in July and in
some years back in London again in
November our next group of sessions will
be in London meeting from February the
6th to the 9th at Church Westminster
just across the river from where we're
um where we are this morning
by now hopefully you will have received
a batch of papers by email about an hour
ago
those are also being sent to members of
Sinnoh this morning and all will be
published on the Synod page of the
church Amino website in fact they've
been published a few moments ago don't
be too alarmed it's a large pile of
papers don't be too alarmed by the
volume we should be able to help you
navigate those this morning the key is
just a little tip is to look at the
agenda which is paper
gs2283 that's gs2283 which sets out the
timetable for discussions and also
details uh
um important other details such as the
exact wording of the proposed motions
so before we look in detail at the
living in love and faith prayers and
resources I'd like to invite William to
give us a brief overview of what else is
coming up at synod
thank you Mark and thank you everyone
for coming
rather more interest in our press
conference than some years so there may
be some newcomers or people unfamiliar
with the work of the general Synod I'm
going to give you a very brief
introduction to the synod's work and to
the business the Senate will be doing at
the forthcoming group of sessions from
February the 6th to the 9th
I do realize of course that most of you
will be most interested to hear from
Bishop Sarah the archbishops about The
Bishop's response to living in love and
faith so I do promise to be very brief
before handing over to them to deal with
that part of the agenda
the general Synod is the Church of
England's national legislative and
deliberative body it is sometimes called
the church's Parliament and it does
resemble parliament in that its
principal business is to legislate that
is to make law
for the church which is because the
Church of England is an established
church also part of the law of the land
the Synod will devote quite a bit of
time in February to this primary
law-making function
Parliament has devolved to the Synod the
power to legislate for the church
subject to a procedure which takes our
draft measures the equivalent of
parliamentary bills back through the
houses of Commons and Lords once they
have been approved in the synod
and the Synod comprises three houses
Bishops clergy and laity the clergy and
laity elected from the dioceses of the
church
the main elements of business next month
will be living in love and faith
obviously which you'll hear about in a
moment
but also three other kinds of business
first the legislation including on
matters like safeguarding where we are
implementing one of the recommendations
of the independent inquiry into child
sexual abuse
Church pensions
church finance enabling wealthier
dioceses to help poorer dioceses
financially
and fees setting the standard fees for
weddings and funeral services
secondly dealing with matters of wider
public interest for example we have a
debate on the cost of living and how the
church is helping and can help people
affected
and we have a debate on the rate of
insurance premium tax
and we will be inviting the Synod to
present a loyal address to his majesty
the king
and thirdly business relating to the
church itself but without legislation
living in love and faith falls into this
category
but we also have a debate on proposals
to simplify the governance of Our
National Church functions
a debate on reforming how we pay for the
training of clergy
under presentation and debate about
progress on safeguarding
this also includes some standard bits of
similar business notably the Synod
Question Time session when members of
Synod can ask questions of various
bodies in the church
I imagine that most of you will want to
move on to hear about llf but before we
do that I would be happy to try to deal
with any questions you may have about
the rest of the agenda
are there any questions
about the operation of Synod happy to go
through those
let me now turn our attention to llf it
gives me great pleasure to welcome the
bishop of London Sarah malali to talk
about llf
thank you
mark and um uh thank you for coming it's
uh it's good to be with you and also
those online we're we're glad that you
could join us as Mark said my name is
Sarah Mullally and I've chaired uh the
next steps group over the last two and a
half years the next steps group is made
up of bishops from the church of England
and we've been steering this process but
in doing that we have been accompanied
by a reference group which are people
with diverse lived experiences and
convictions
back in 2017 the archbishops the house
and the house of Bishops commissioned a
major study of human identity sexuality
relationships and marriage in the
context of the Christian faith changes
in society and the disagreements within
not just the wider church but the Church
of England the result was a suite of
teaching and Learning Resource which was
published in November 2011 2020 under
the banner of living in love and faith
and I'm very pleased to see that the
Archbishop of canterbury's copy is very
well fund
um the teaching and learning resources
were designed to be accessible they
included not just the book but also
video based course there were films and
there were podcasts they told stories of
individual couple couples and families
with diverse lived experiences and
convictions about sexuality identity and
relationships during 2020 2021 and 2022
the Bishops encouraged Church
communities around the country to use
the resources to learn together to
listen to one another and also to God
thousands of people took part in fact
over 6 000 people responded to a
questionnaire about the experience of
learning together
many sent poems and artwork in response
to the topics that they explored
this was the first church-wide process
of this type in the Church of England
we the Bishops also played our part in
living in love and faith we were
involved in drafting the book we
encourage people in our diocese to take
part in the llf course and we engaged
with the resources ourselves alongside
studying scripture and reflecting on the
church's tradition
we then listened to what people said
the things that they said about the
matters in living in love and faith and
the issues that that raised
towards the end of last year and earlier
this week the Bishops have been meeting
together to discern what we believe God
is saying to the church
we are accompanied in this process by 12
people again representing the diverse
lived experiences and condition
convictions Who provided a non-episcal
in a sense what we're really saying they
were Bishops and they provided their
perspective and held us to account in
that process and we are very grateful
for what they offer to us recognizing
that for some it also cost them
together the Bishops have studied the
scriptures we have paid attention to the
church tradition and we have listened to
wider society as well as the voices of
our sister churches in the Anglican
communion and our ecumenical partners
of all we have sought the wisdom of the
holy spirit in prayer and worship
says uh within the Church of England are
also present among the Bishops of the
Church of England
engaging with living in love and faith
process has enabled us to become more
open and honest with each other
that has been an important part of the
process which means uh and and I think
has given us a greater understanding of
what it means uh to be living together
as members of the body of Christ
being honest has not erased our
disagreements
it has deepened our relationship and our
desire to continue to work with one
another seeking the Deep deeper Unity
for the church for which Christ prayed
for
some clear developments have emerged
from our discussions that impact are a
series of Firsts for the Church of
England
in an open letter we together apologize
for the pain hostility exclusion and
rejection that lgbtqi people have
experienced within the church
we realize that this Behavior has not
reflected the universal love of God for
all people we know that we need to
change
and Archbishop Stephen will speak more
on this shortlist shortly
in our letter because we work we write a
letter to the church we express our
joyful affirmation and celebration of
lgbtqi people in our church communities
and we have begun to produce a suite of
prayers
these prayers are known as prayers of
love and faith
they mean that same-sex couples who are
faithful and seek a lifelong
relationship will be able to come into
churches in the Church of England for
prayers of dedication Thanksgiving and
of God's blessing after for example
coming to a significant point of their
relationship or entering a civil
partnership or marriage
for the first time the church churches
within the Church of England will be
able to do this this is a real first
until now same-sex couples have had no
way of publicly expressing their desire
to put God at the center of their
relationship and commitment to one
another in a church of England Church
these prayers can be used flexibly for
relationships at different stages and in
different contexts services that use
these prayers are not marriage services
and their use by clergy is entirely
voluntary
this means that the church can continue
to embrace the different perspectives
that are held by clergy and
congregations within the Church of
England about same-sex marriage
and same-sex relationships we realize
that for some this will be deeply
disappointing particularly for those who
long for equal marriage for same-sex
couple
we also realize that for others among us
there will be a deep concern that the
prayers of love and faith will go too
far your consciences and Theological
convictions will not allow you to use
them
any discussion around identity sexuality
relationships and marriage involved
deeply held convictions across the
spectrum of lived experiences and
Theological understanding
people's personal identities and
interpretation of scriptures are caught
up in this process
it is inevitable that from a wide range
of perspectives there will be many
feelings which may include vulnerability
fear sadness resignation anger as well
as joy and Hope
along with this we live in a society in
which we often are pressured towards
adversarial Behavior
as God's church we are called to a
different way by being honest about our
own disagreements and through gracious
interpretation of Doctrine we will honor
the reality of our differences within
the Church of England
and across the Anglican Union and among
our ecumenical partners
we hope to model this by providing
prayers that bear a Nuance a variety and
of understanding
this is not about enforcing Unity but it
is about pursuing it by the grace of God
what we must do is create gracious space
for the Holy Spirit to fill as we stay
faithful to Jesus Christ rooted and
grounded in the love of God
thank you I'm now going to pass over to
Ava who will talk more about the detail
thank you Bishop Sarah and thank you for
your interest and for coming today it
has been I must say my privilege to
serve the living in love and faith
process over the last five or so years
so what has changed what's different now
what will it look like for lgbtqi plus
people and for churches around the
country
we have published a draft set of prayers
of love and faith
these resources contain prayers Bible
readings and other resources that can be
used within a service that celebrates a
committed relationship between two
people
so a same-sex couple who may have
entered a civil partnership or marriage
will have a conversation with a clergy
person together they will look at the
resources in the prayers of love and
faith and create a personalized service
in which they can celebrate their
relationship give thanks to God and
receive prayers of God's blessing on
them
the prayers here in these resources
include a prayer of dedication for
example of commitment of Thanksgiving
for the gift of love and for God's
blessing on a couple
they include prayers that may be said
with or by the couple the resource also
suggests suitable Bible readings and
gives some examples of how a service
using these prayers might be put
together so that it is truly
personalized for the couple
a service could in fact include a prayer
as a couple make their home together
so this is a major change for the Church
of England and our hope is that it will
enable the church together with the
family and friends of the couple to
joyfully affirm and celebrate their love
and their commitment and faithfulness to
one another before God
but living in love and faith is about
much more than same-sex relationships
it's strap line is human identity
sexuality relationships and marriage
so as important as the question of
same-sex relationships is and it is
important
a number of other things have been put
forward by the Bishops
so for example they have announced their
plan to create a new suite of pastoral
guidance that will replace guidance that
is no longer fit for purpose called
issues in human sexuality written over
30 years ago
this guidance will help churches to
better carry out their responsibility to
offer pastoral care to all people in
their parishes in a genuinely inclusive
way
it will also help the church in its
discernment and expectations of people
who might be wishing to explore a
ministerial vocation in the church
one of the aims of the living and love
and faith project was to enable the
church to better live out its calling in
the context of a 21st century
understanding of Being Human and being
sexual
both the church and wider Society are
faced with new challenges that concern
human identity and relationships these
include for example our need to reflect
on what it means to be embodied human
beings in an increasingly virtual world
and in a world where the concept of
gender for example has become fluid
we also live in the society with a
growing number of single people both
young and old
human beings are created to be in
relationship
relationships are the stuff of everyday
human life and flourishing
so how do we express and enact genuine
welcome and acceptance that enables the
flourishing of the diversity of people
and relationships that form the everyday
lives of people in our communities that
is what the church is called to so how
do we speak into this the wisdom of
Christian understanding and of God's
Good Will to all people
these are some of the areas that Bishops
agree the church needs to attend to in
an exploratory participatory and
inclusive way so much has happened
much work still to do
thank you very much
um we will be taking questions in the
second half of the press conference but
I would now I'd like to ask Archbishop
Justin for his personal reflections
just to put this uh slightly into
historical context
questions around sexuality relationships
and marriage have been debated by all
Global churches for a very long time uh
certainly 40 or 50 years in the Church
of England we've been looking seriously
at this and there have been resolutions
at General Senate and papers and
discussions since the 1970s
but that has picked up a lot in the last
10 years as culture has changed very
rapidly in our society
and I really want to say these are not
academic debates or theological debates
as Ava uh and uh Sarah have commented
this is about the lived experience of
normal human beings every day with those
they love and who love them and working
out
how to do that
what works what's right and wrong
and very often and Archbishop Stephen
will say something about this in a
moment
very often the way the church has
responded has been negative and harmful
the living in love and faith the llf
project
also hasn't been about people
it's been with people and that's
probably the biggest change in our
working methods in 2017 a paper was
brought to the general Senate which the
Synod rejected
and rather than bring yet another uh
series of small papers we sat down and
and
worked as Sarah's already described on a
process which led to this book I commend
it very strongly to you it's very light
reading
[Music]
compared to what it might be
um and in the process of producing this
work it started with a couple of years
of deep theological thinking from people
of all views
and very different experiences of
sexuality
went on to two years in which the
streams of thinking which were biblical
uh philosophical ethical historical
and scientific about the psychological
and
um biological sciences
in which those streams were mixed up and
produced in the end this work and within
those streams and when those who did
this work were people who were laying to
ordained people who were gay and
straight people who fell in every single
category so it was done with people not
to them
and there's been a really deep listening
you'll find many stories in here it's
got lots of good stories
um about different people's experience
and that resulted in the book being
published discussions at the general
Senate and Sarah very kindly in addition
to other our other duties
Bishop of London with Ava who's worked
the right way her way through
um uh working for two and a half years
on what we did about it so not just
producing a resource but saying okay how
are we going to act on this
it's been the most extensive and
in-depth effort of any major Faith group
in exploring these questions and many
other Global churches are looking on
this as a major resource it's a very
high quality resource
we've also walked broadened
those who are involved in making the
decision historically
when I first became Bishop 10 years ago
everything was done by the senior
Bishops
and everyone else was told what had been
decided
and they did agree with it didn't they
and it's now this last discussion uh
over the last
two and a half years involved What's
called the College of Bishops which is
every Bishop
and on Tuesday when we met at the Excel
Center
um there were over 100 Bishops uh in the
room and they all and it was a gracious
passionate robust but immensely
United discussion which resulted in an
overwhelming majority for the direction
in which we're going at the moment
it's the first time the entire college
has been involved historically ever in
making these kinds of decisions
and it's brought us together as Sarah
said Hugh and Ava huge honesty
transparency and friendship and love
and I hope and pray that as we go from
here
um to the general Synod next month the
the vast majority of voices will have
that similar concern for each other
as it happened I had a meeting last
night with about 50 people
from all shades of opinion within the
church and we were discussing this at
some length it was a supper and
everyone was listening carefully to each
other it wasn't a single discussion
everybody was talking and the mood was
extraordinarily positive this is a
moment of joy and celebration
we have actually made decisions and they
are decisions which change our approach
to
lgbtqi plus people
we also say in these papers and the
press release
uh in particular that we're divided
and that's there's no point in
pretending otherwise the Church of
England and the Anglican communion are
very divided those of you who followed
the Lambeth conference in uh July August
will remember that and
um that brings me to my own position on
this the Anglican communion is a
communion not a single church it's 43
churches around the world in 165
countries with over 2 000 languages and
cultures
we scarcely agree on anything in daily
life and experience apart from the
God in his love and grace came as fully
human without losing any of being God in
order to reach out to every human being
whatever their sexuality or color or
race or gender or capacity or incapacity
to reach out to them
and to draw them into the experience of
God's love
the message of the church and to living
communities that reflect that love and
that difference
when a communion has people who range
from
uh someone I met a few years back whose
grandfather
in the hills of Papua New Guinea was the
first man of his ethnic group ever to
see a wheel
through to people who have advanced phds
from
um uh top universities in the United
States and work on Wall Street
you know are we going to agree on
everything
Dream On
totally different life experiences
the Anglican communion's Miracle is not
that it has differences but that it
loves one another despite them that's
extraordinary it's a sign of God's grace
and goodness
and my role as Archbishop of Canterbury
uh is nowhere described as a human being
which may not surprise many people uh
but he's described as an instrument of
communion and a focus of unity I have a
pastoral responsibility for the whole
communion
I've often prayed and will continue to
pray with all sorts and kinds of people
with all sorts and kinds of problems
including
many people who came
looking for
um
the experience of God's love
uh who who were gay or who were straight
or who had trouble with their marriage
or were worried about their
relationships and I'll continue to pray
for all those who come seeking prayer
and to pray with love and a deep sense
that most Koji have of the privilege of
being allowed into these sacred parts of
people's lives
but because of my pastoral care and
responsibility and being a focus of
unity for the whole communion
I will while being extremely joyfully
celebratory of these new resources
I will not personally use them
in order not to compromise that pastoral
care
for example which will need to be
exercised next week
uh when the pope and the moderation of
the Church of Scotland and I go on a
pilgrimage of peace to the South Sudan
where half a million people have died
from Civil War in the last nine years
and
that
I
that is a self-denying ordinance
but it comes out of the global
responsibility so in summary it's a long
journey I'm sure the last word hasn't
been said
and I'm sure the discussions will
continue
but this is an enormously important
Point not only within the Anglican
communion and the church of England but
also across the global Church in which
we seek to recognize
and to celebrate the love that all
people have for one another regardless
of who they are and where they're from
and I am filled with joy about that
and last night with all those
differences
people
shared their views and their feelings
which were almost all positive
with great joy that we take in this step
thank you
thank you very much Bishop Justin I'm
now going to call on Archbishop Stephen
for his own personal Reflections and to
let you know that then
Ava will be circling back with the
Practical explanation of what will be
happening at Synod and how these
materials are going to be
uh uh socialize and approved yeah thank
you
yeah so so it may be a long journey but
you're almost on the last lap of the
presentations and you'll get a chance to
ask questions
um and uh and I thought I'd just start
by saying uh you know since Tuesday uh I
spoke with the priest yesterday uh yeah
yesterday day before uh in the York
diocese where I serve
and she said when I when I not so much
heard the news when I digested the news
when I kind of understood what's really
being offered here she said I wept
and um and I said
I wasn't quite sure how to interpret her
tears I I thought is you know is it
because
is it because you're so distressed by
what has happened or what hasn't
happened and she said no she said but
could I just check out does it mean that
if there's a same-sex couple in my
Parish you get married does it mean I
can invite them to church that we can
acknowledge I said yeah yeah that's what
it means
so they were tears of joy now I know
that's not where everybody is
um I know that's not where everybody is
but I think I want to emphasize
this does put the Church of England in a
new place
um and I believe it's a good place
um and it's a good place because it
holds the unity of the church
but it also enables
lgbtqi plus people to be part of that
church and have their lived experience
their love for each other acknowledged
in the church and I'm really sorry
you know one thing we've learned in this
process
is just how much damage we've done I
don't think we didn't mean to do it
nobody gets up in the morning saying
they want to hurt and damage people but
we have we have
um and I also know that saying sorry
doesn't cut it for some people it sounds
Hollow it's all very well you saying
sorry the church still isn't giving us
what we want that is what how some
people are responding and I want to say
yeah I do get that but it doesn't mean
the story isn't still heartfelt
and also the story now is coming from a
place of being informed you know we've
spent so much time listening and working
with people across a whole range of
diversities it has brought us to a new
knowledge and a new place of humility
before God before church before the
world where we can say yes we got it
wrong
and we're not saying by the way we think
we've got it right now but we are saying
this is a good place to be
um where we can live together with our
disagreements and fully acknowledge and
welcome into the church
lgbtqi plus people and the other thing I
want to say sorry for is you know I'm
not I'm not getting at the journalist we
love you as well but we're really sorry
the news leaked
we're really sorry the news leaked
because it meant that the people who
would be hurt most by the news those who
are most vulnerable heard the story not
in the way that we want to tell the
story and we're really sorry that
happened
so let me finish with a with a story
which which perhaps helps make sense of
the change that's happening because of
what we're announcing today so I have a
dear friend one of one of my dearest
oldest closest friends he died uh two
years ago in the opening you know the
opening months of a covert thing
uh he was a priest
he was in a long-term lifelong stable
committed relationship with another
priest that they met at theological
College
um and they were in a lifelong
partnership
when civil marriage not civil marriage
when civil part when was that civil
partnership came in in in you know 15 20
years ago whenever that came in they
entered into a civil partnership
Faithfully following the rules and
disciplines of the church and entered
into a civil partnership
they invited me to the Civil partnership
ceremony these are some of my closest
friends I was delighted to go
rather naughtily they tried to smuggle
into the service a reading from the
Bible which as you may know in the Civil
partnership legislation you will not
know prayers no readings from the Bible
were allowed they tried to smuggle one
in they chose that passage from the song
of songs beautiful passage many Waters
cannot quench love neither can the
floods drown it and they kind of hurt
because it didn't specifically mention
God or Jesus the Civil celebram wouldn't
notice it was from the Bible civil
celebrant did notice it was from the
Bible there's a whole little bit of
wrangling going on before the ceremony
began they had to remove it
and I sat there
you know and I was heartbroken but here
these people who love each other whose
relationships so exhibits all that I
would want and expect from a
relationship who taught me so much about
love and sacrifice and they couldn't
even have this little reading from the
Bible and much of that was down to us in
the church because of what we'd asked
the government to do and this and it was
great party afterwards and the party was
in the garden of the church
where one of them was the minister so
we're standing in the garden of the
church there's the church
we're celebrating their marriage in the
garden we couldn't go into the church we
couldn't even go into the church and say
a prayer
um don't
don't misunderstand what's happening
today
all that changes
and I'm really I'm really pleased it's
changing
I'm really pleased it's changing for my
you know gay friends
I'm really pleased and no it's not
enough for some and I'm really sorry
it's not enough and I wasn't expecting
to get emotional
but um
but I am
because I think it puts the Church of
England in a better place and I really
hope that we can hold together our Unity
and I cry out for those who hate what
we're doing and say we want to hold you
together in this but this is the fullest
pastoral provision that we can offer at
the moment without changing legislation
which would take Years anyway years and
years
we can offer this soon
and I thank God for it and I hope it
will be well received in our church
and in our world
thank you thank you Archbishop Stephen
what I'd like to do now just before we
go to questions is just call back Ava to
talk through what's going to be
happening at Synod over those three days
thank you thank you very much Mark and
I'll be really quick I imagine you're
waiting to to ask questions so uh what's
happening at Synod given that actually
officially
um these are things that Bishops can
already do go ahead and do but actually
the Bishops decided that it's really
important to gauge the mind of sin or to
listen to what Synod members are
thinking about these matters and how
they're responding to the Bishops uh
proposed way forward so there's going to
be uh events at on each of the first
three days of Synod relating to living
love and faith on day one on Monday
there will be a shortish presentation
just to kind of set the scene explain
how the Bishops have come to the the
decisions that they have made and the
plans that they are putting forward for
future work
then on day two Synod members will be
invited to do some group work they will
uh Gather in groups and reflect first of
all on uh Archbishop Justin was just
talking about about how do we engage
with one another well when we disagree
and when we're talking about things that
are so deeply personal uh so they spent
a bit of time doing that because they
can use the Pastoral principles that
were developed as part of the living
love and faith process to think about
what sometimes gets in the way of our
relationships and of relating well
across difference they'll spend a little
bit of time doing that and then having
done that they will look at the prayers
of love and faith they'll look at the
proposal for new pastoral guidance and
they will share their Reflections on
that and importantly those Reflections
will be gathered up and fed back in a
plenary session at the end of the day
important to say that uh doing group
work can be difficult when when we're
talking about matters like this so we've
made sure that their external
facilitators for each group we've made
sure that there are clear ground rules
so that the groups can hopefully have a
really fruitful and productive
conversation together and then
importantly at the end of the day
Gathering up the feedback from those
groups because Bishops really want to
hear what it is that Synod members are
thinking
then on the third day there will be a
more traditional debate and the Bishops
have put forward a multi-pronged motion
and Synod will have up to five hours if
you can imagine that to debate the
motion and the motion invites Synod to
join in apologizing on behalf of the
church to lgbtqi plus people it invites
the Lord to embed those pastoral
principles that I just mentioned as a
means of learning how to live well
together across our differences in
invites Synod members to commit to
continuing to learn together in the way
that the living and love and faith
process has tried to embody it will
invite sin or members to welcome the
Bishops Commendation of prayers of love
and faith when they are finalized these
are just draft and finally they will
invite Synod members to consider having
a period of about five years to just
follow how have they been used and how
what can we learn and and then review
after a period of five years so three
different things happening on three uh
sequential days in Synod uh to really uh
hopefully give Synod members every
opportunity to share their own
Reflections uh to the church thank you
thank you very much Ava uh I'd now like
to open the floor to the questions our
colleagues Kimberly and Fabian you know
have two roving mics so to ensure that
those watching online uh and uh
recording can pick up your question
please do wait until the mics get to you
before speaking and also can I just as a
formality could you state your name and
publication thank you
Harriet yes
Harriet Show with the guardian
um Archbishop Justin has been
commendably clear on
um the fact that he will not offer
blessings himself personally and has
very been very clear about the reasons
for that artificial Steve and you
haven't said whether you will could you
clarify that please
I mean yes I I will
um I mean I completely support and
understand Archbishop Justin's position
but his position is different to mine
um uh so
um that that's what I'm I imagine will
happen and that this is all stored and
go through but yes
Kaya hello hi and hello I've seen the
teaching that that marriage and holy
sorry Kaya Burgess from the Times
newspaper
um with the teaching that holy matrimony
remains between a man and a woman and
the teaching has always been that on a
dual sense that gay people should remain
celibate and that sex should take place
within marriage
what is the position for the church now
people gay Christians have been asking
we can come to church now have a civil
marriage come to church and have that
relationship blessed are we still
expected by the church to remain
celibate or is it now understood if the
marriage is blessed sex should take
place within marriage that gay couples
are allowed to express themselves
sexually as well
I think the um I thank you thank you for
your question and and I recognize it's a
question that many many uh are proposing
I think that
um what we recognize that within the
College of Bishop there will be a range
of views that that are held on that
um what the what we are doing is
proposing uh prayers uh for people at
the stage of their relationship and
within that relationship and we're
specifically saying it is a faithful
lifelong relationship between two people
is that though and I think one thing I
have learned through listening is that
there are a whole range of ways in which
people will Express that relationship
and some will be sexual some will not
some will be friendship uh some will you
know some will be sexual and so the
prayers are there that uh that uh um
that can be offered and I think that the
way they will be used is there will be a
range of ways in which they will be used
in that so there will be uh the POS the
opportunity for those people in a
same-sex relationship to come and have
that relationship blessed and of course
some of those will be sexual
thank you Harry
Potter from BBC News um you mentioned
there was a range of views in the house
of Bishops on that question perhaps
Archbishop Stephen and Bishop Sarah
could I just ask for your personal views
do you think that gay sex in the context
of a loving committed lifelong
relationship is a sin
I think as as Bishop Sarah has just said
um if if people who have as I imagine
this going forward if people who have
entered into a same-sex civil marriage
come to the church
um
seeking one of these Services of love
and faith
um in the same way that actually with
heterosexual couples you know who come
seeking holy matrimony and one notices
um
they have the same address for instance
when they fill in the forms
I don't I don't ask them questions about
I celebrate the fact that they are
wanting to commit themselves in a stable
loving relationship
I believe the great gift of sexual and
physical intimacy
um to be cherished belongs in stable
loving committed relationships
and therefore I will celebrate the fact
that people are living that way and
expressing their intimacy that way
thank you
um yes
Tim sixworth press Association
um given the census figures on the
decline of religious belief in this
country
um the other month what do you say to
those who would say that there is this
is a pretty desperate attempt to appear
more relevant to secular society while
also
in a way engaging with those who hold
the Orthodox position on human sexuality
would I want that role
um
you know I think it's I think there's um
I think there's a lot that we need to
learn from the the the data that we see
both about uh the declining in and
people identifying as religious as well
as
um where we've seen decline within the
church
um and I and I think that we have to
take that seriously often I recognize
that that is patchy there are some
churches that are growing and that would
be true with it you know the London
diocese holds its own if not grows I
think that in London I think that people
may uh actually
um be more have they make a greater
commitment now to be part of a church
than they have previously I see you know
I confirm huge numbers of people huge
numbers of people who want to make a a
decision to follow Jesus Christ so
actually I think those figures we have
to pay attention and look at and also I
think that people tend to be spiritual
although not always belong so there's a
real date that I wouldn't underplay the
need for us to reflect on them but also
to recognize uh where the where the
church is in contact with people
this has been this it has been a um a
process where we have been as a church
uh listening to people's lived
experience we have been reading
scripture that we have been very aware
of our tradition and in a sense that is
what we have been reflecting on not
necessarily the question of relevance to
our society that that isn't of course we
are part of you know there is a church
in every single Community we we are the
established church so therefore part of
our listening has been to those around
us but it's not about relevance it has
been about trying to discern uh what God
is calling us to do and I think we
recognize that within the church there
is a diversity of you as with is as
there is within uh the College of
Bishops and I think what we're saying is
recognizing that diversity this is our
response that we are making to that that
living in love and faith and I do think
that one of the things for me about her
first I mean there's always been
difference in the College of Bishops but
it this is a first and probably saying
well actually there is a difference
and actually our risk our response was
over it was overwhelmingly a majority to
put this proposed this proposal this is
our response for and therefore we are
saying that with our diversity we are
seeking to walk in unity which it isn't
about forcing it but about saying with
the grace of God we will continue to do
that
um
this is Kelly from Premiere it's if I'm
understanding this correctly you're
saying that um sexual intimacy it's now
upped for each couple to the side is
that the case for gay priests as well
and what would you say um to those who
might argue that the role of the church
is to have a clear Doctrine on all and
on these issues and for its members to
abide to it
what what I do realize is that there
um is that a lot of the questions that
are being put to us not from journalists
but from an individual relate to
questions that uh individual clergy will
have and I think one of the things that
we had very clearly was that
um in terms of our pastoral response to
the lgbtq uh people who who are clergy
is that we haven't we we have not done
that well enough and a lot of that
discernment of vocation and where their
role is has been uh shaped partly by uh
issues in human sexuality which was a a
book that was written I think probably
30 years ago it wasn't written for that
purpose and so therefore we have clearly
heard that that is not acceptable to
continue on using that book so there are
will be pastoral guidance that will be
put in place and therefore that the use
of that book for that reason will stop
when that happens and I think one of one
of my regrets is that I couldn't be
sitting here today and saying these are
the Pastoral guidance but that's not
where we are we would hope that
certainly by the time the sin had met in
July that there would be clear pastoral
guidance uh
um in place and part of the opportunity
at Synod is also in the group work to to
listen to people's Reflections about
where we are where the air is in which
we want to focus on on those guidance
sorry what would you say to those who um
might argue that um the church should
have a clear Doctrine on issues such as
this and that its church members that
shoot a bite to it
so I clear Doctrine on what sorry
yeah well we agree that there needs to
be Clarity
um moral ethical doctrinal Clarity
um uh so we would agree
um but obviously what we are
framing here and what will be
articulated more in the Pastoral
guidance is is where you know where
those boundaries are
um and how we are going to live
Faithfully within them but yes that you
know we do need to acknowledge there is
a change today is that we are
acknowledging
um the goodness and faithfulness of
same-sex civil marriages and civil
Partnerships within the life of the
church and that opens up a number of
questions for us which the Pastoral
guidance will I just suppose we'll
answer all of them but we will answer
the really pressing ones
anyway remember
just to say it on this question of
sexual intimacy in relation to marriage
and absolutely although the canons of
the Church of England don't say anything
explicitly about that it has been the
teaching of the Church of England that
marriage is the best place for sexual
intimacy and I think we do need to
acknowledge that there is difference
among the Bishops and within the church
about that some people would say that
that absolutely stands that that sexual
intimacy is is only uh good in a
heterosexual marriage holy matrimony uh
and whereas others would take a more
generous stand so it is something that
we disagree about but we're talking
about it and I think that is hugely
helpful and healthy one of the things
that we point out in the Pastoral
principles is is that the danger of
silence and having opening up this
conversation is I think really important
and really helpful
okay yeah see you next time
sorry Susie Leaf uh freelance but here
asking questions for English Churchman
and Christian today
um the Archbishop of Canterbury you you
referred to the Lambeth conference and
the joy of that
um do you think that you're self-denying
ordinance which is you know I can see
something that is going to as it were
hurt
um do you think that will be enough to
keep the Anglican communion together
considering what the global South
Fellowship said at Lambeth about not
being able to walk together with those
who bless same-sex relationships
we've been thank you Susie uh We've uh
is it right if I answer this one
you're in charge
um we um uh
the Lambeth conference was an
extraordinary moment
because uh
on the Tuesday of the Lambeth conference
the first Tuesday we uh
discuss this at some length knowing how
deeply divided we were and knowing that
there were very extensive groups outside
the
Hall and outside the Bishops who were
using all kinds of ready quite
unpleasant methods to try and get people
to split and divide
offering money and things
and so it was a really remarkable moment
the afternoon ended with people of
entirely opposite views
embracing each other and spending the
rest of that week in United prayer
and agreement it was a very remarkable
thing
we've been quite clear and we were quite
clear on that Tuesday that there are
widely different views
that the vast majority of the Anglican
communion hold to the traditional View
and since that point I have been
regularly in contact with the primates
of the Anglican communion in the 42
other provinces and visiting a number of
them
uh not to talk about this but um talking
about in the course of a visit
and we had a special primates meeting
just before Christmas
and I've been in touch just before the
press release was issued on the day
before yesterday I think it was
and
um the response has been
predictable
but muted and generous
uh I can't I can't predict the future I
don't know what the response will be to
my self-denying ordinance I'm not doing
it in order to hold the community
together I'm doing it because I think
it's right
and I'd add that to what Sarah and
Stephen said no this is not a desperate
effort to reverse the decline of the
church thing and that didn't come up in
the discussions we did it not out of
expedience because we think it's right
and I would add in the way that the when
you see the prayers in the way they're
written and thought about
um that they fall very clearly within uh
to lapse into technical language what is
described as Lambeth one point
resolution
uh Lambeth 1.10
1998 of the
1998 Lambeth Conference of Bishops
resolution 110 as it's called
um which has about six paragraphs or
five paragraphs like I can never quite
remember uh and there's one which you
mentioned which
um says we can't bear same-sex marriages
and
um this
uh seeks to bless the people
and that's really important and there
are other paragraphs
that uh say we cannot exhibit homophobia
uh very very clearly that bit is usually
forgotten and very often ignored
and we've had some I've had some very
public disagreements with
uh primates of the global South who've
ignored the latter part as well as the
former part
so
um well little I don't know I don't know
I'm hopeful I pray it will because
I believe that it is emphatically
Jesus's prayer and command that the
church holds together through its
disagreements and failure to do that is
to go straight against the prayer and
command of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ
thank you and we have five more minutes
left for questions Harriet yes
if the church is going to offer
blessings to people who've undergone a
civil marriage where does that leave
clergy who have undergone civil
marriages but have then been barred from
ministry as a result
uh that is a explicitly the question
that the Pastoral guidance will address
um so so I think what we our aim is to
produce um so the Pastoral guidance will
not be a book that goes on a shelf the
Pastoral guidance will be ongoing uh
guidance recognizing that they'll be in
need as the world changes so we will
expedite
um very quickly those that relate to the
most pressing issues and so for me to
say that I said think I said before
those are the sort of guidance are all
absolutely
um I hope anyway I have every intention
that they are in place but well before
the July synod
thank you
thanks uh Eleanor ITV News um uh
Archbishop ITV News National
yeah that's all good can you hear me now
um
a couple of things how can the church
offer God's blessing to something which
because of Doctrine it's it does say it
can't recognize or accept and and what
would you say to couples who think that
it's pointless to look for a blessing
from a church that doesn't actually
really want to marry them
absolutely
I think I might want to I want to start
with the second one because I actually
think um
you know I think that that what has
already said this has been a significant
change
um uh here and that for the church to be
able to offer prayers of blessings that
somebody who wants their uh partnership
blessed in church this is it you know
this is is it will be possible but of
course we've also said they are
voluntary and therefore it may well be
that not every church will offer them
but that is still the con that is still
the position around
um the celebr in the marriage of
um those that are divorced
um in church that not every every Church
offers that and and therefore I think
that if a couple words were approach a
church that were not
um
not offering the prayers
um I in the same ways that happens now
that they would be generously welcomed
and May and in and actually helped along
the way to find the church and
everything that could offer it and I
think also going back to a point that
ever made that my expectation is that
this is a couple or that also want to
celebrate it specifically
um
um you know they want to God's blessing
on them it's about celebrating uh their
relationship faithful relationship
um recognizing that they want to do that
with God involved and and therefore I I
sort of hope that these are couples that
are also involved in the local church
they already have a relationship with
the church and I think that's that is
the real opportun opportunity so I think
um you know therefore I would hope that
they would explore that conversation
because this is will be the first time
that they will be able
um to do that yeah okay one more
question
thank you uh Francis Martin from church
times
at the start of this week
um MPS from from across the political
Spectrum uh publicly expressed their
hope that the Church of England would uh
accept endorse same-sex marriage
um and many of them uh added that the
established status of the church
um could be up for discussion if the
church did not do so do you think that
what has been announced today will
placate those MPS is that or is that an
ongoing concern
um I'd be interested in your Reflections
perhaps on the discussions uh informal
behind closed doors perhaps that have
been ongoing with parliamentarians
obviously can't discuss questions behind
closed doors because they were behind
closed doors
um I don't think we know about them yes
I'm not aware of them so you know you
know more than we do which is often the
case here yeah
um uh
I think it's a question for Parliament
I think you have to ask them
um I can't and we we're in constant
touch with
um
parliamentarians with all sorts of views
um
uh and
um
I just don't know the I don't think I've
got a
valuable answer to them it's not
intended to placate them that had no
influence at all this is not an
expedient point
it is a point that we felt was right
and I remember
like Stephen it just came his face and
name came to my mind just as you were
asking the question
if someone who was a very strong member
of the church
where I was many years ago very many
years ago whereas Parish priest
and
um one of the parish priests there and
uh
he was single
and I suppose some years after I left
when he came out
as gay it wasn't a huge surprise
but the next thing I heard was
that the pressure of living with the
church's attitude
had led
to his suicide
I still mourn him
and I wish he was here today
because I think he would be
able
to feel that perhaps it wasn't
everything you wanted
but it said that he wasn't a lesser
what we've done and are doing and we'll
go on doing
says he's not lesser he's not excluded
he's not unloved he's not unwanted
but he's um as much a valuable loved
saved member of God's people
because he's put his trust and life in
the hands of Jesus Christ
as any other person
who has done that
so I'm
in a sense like Stephen
I'm really pleased
that we've done what we've done
and
I just wish that certain people
could be here today
and no budget
thank you
I'm afraid we are out of time I uh
the two archbishops need to be somewhere
else very shortly so I would like to
thank you very very much for coming we
will see many of you at synod uh I know
that some of you have arranged some
one-on-one interviews John's going to
come up now and just talk about the
logistics of that but I'd really a very
warm thanks from all of us for coming
today and we look forward to seeing you
with Synod as well thank you
oh
foreign